arnaud de thézac bonjour oui bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france alors on
le disait mardi les ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'union
européenne on ont plaidé ensemble pour
un cessez le feu une protection des
civils un accès de l'aide humanitaire à
gaza
un droit d'israël à se défendre mais en
respectant le droit humanitaire
international mais la hongrie elle elle
n'a pas souscrit à ces prises de
position pourquoi j'avais prédit fier de
répondre à l'emporter 1 c'est un sujet
qui telle complexité qui les ai faites
une telle perspective historique mais
pour résumer on peut quand même
comprendre la position normale dans dans
sa posture patriotique donc avec un la
défense d'un pays qui est souverain chez
lui qui était frontières et ça s'est il
râlait un modèle de ce point de vue là
oui du point de vue d'un état nation qui
qui qui défend ses frontières et le
discours d'israël aujourd'hui c'est bon
voilà on a été attaquée ont défoncé la
légitime défense et donc il voulait la
tradition durban elle est cohérente avec
un discours qui est un discours non
européaniste et le discours de nos
rock'n européen si vous vous laissez à
30 hier tout le monde il est beau tout
le monde il est gentil et ce travail et
donc quand or bana a construit ces
barrières pour empêcher les flux
migratoires venant de turquie
il s'est fourni en israël est ce qu'il
ya une logique qui n'est pas mon avis
une logique
rattaché au conflit israélo palestinien
la solidarité d'état nation c'est ce
qu'il faut comprendre finalement qu'en
bus doit de peste parle d'une position
européenne qui serait je cite partiale
et déséquilibrée c'est cela alors la
notion d'impartialité de partialité
justement débat piège vous voulez parce
que tout le monde tout le monde a son
opinion tout le monde à sa religion sur
ce conflit là est de se proclamer
impartiale est une gageure quelque part
parce que forcément on va choquer un
camp où on va choquer l'autre mais y ait
une perspective
si vous voulez il ya toujours des
intérêts nationaux et des intérêts
politiques derrière il y a s'ils
voulaient au départ à la création de
l'état d'israël premier pays
enfin groupe de pays dont la hongrie
fait partie 1
c'est quelqu'un qui a reconnu les à
israël le premier lieu à faire des gros
big o le lendemain de la création
d'israël et la première guerre des pays
avoisinants qui ont attaqué et grêle qui
venait de naître a été armée par l'union
soviétique on l'oubli si vous voulez
donc il ya aussi des racines quelque
part historique qui sont existantes
voyez alors ça a duré le temps que ça a
duré mais staline qui vivait encore
voyez dans la création d'israël
un modèle très intéressant de
laboratoire communiste avec les kibboutz
et un moyen de de bouter hors de la
sphère d'influencé arabe l'angleterre
risque plus d'erreurs il ya toujours des
intérêts qui sont mille feuilles
voilà on voyait il ya quelques instants
que la question cette question du
conflit israélo palestinien
elle s'est invitée en france avec des
manifestations encore un rassemblement
hier
est ce que est ce que c'est un dossier
qui est largement couvert par les médias
en hongrie est ce que la question elle
fait aussi débat parmi le peuple
hongrois écouter le peuple hongrois il
est des as et comment dirais-je
volontaire dans son idée d'indépendance
et son idée de teu teu souveraineté donc
de ce point de vue là que vous voulez le
confit de reconnaître la lépi phénomène
et puis il faut bien comprendre une
chose c'est que les choses elles ont
considérablement évolué je dirais il y
avait avant le 6 le la question
palestinienne a existé c'est parce qu'il
y avait énormément d'intérêt également
autour générale a ratifié le terrain
l'egypte tout ça c'est fini aujourd'hui
tout ça sont des pays alliés d'israël
vous voyez ce que je veux donc les
salles le seul allié aujourd'hui qui est
des palestiniens qui étaient fournis en
argent et en armement ya eu les iraniens
ne se sont brouillés
c'est le qatar et éventuellement la
turquie à moi est quelque chose qui est
l'environnement a complètement évolué et
on peut pas si vous voulez revenir à des
à des slogans qui était qui peut être
valable à une certaine époque est qui et
qui aujourd'hui il faut pas forcément
écho avec une réalité géopolitique de
certaines rues donc je pense pas que le
peuple soit forcément très bon sur cette
question et de manière plus générale est
ce qu'il y à il ya d'autres dossiers où
la hongrie finalement ne se retrouve pas
dans la diplomatie européenne
et bien sûr vous avez le fameux cadre de
soros et des douanes pied dont on a tant
parlé en accusant orban d'antisémitisme
alors que sort aux est lui-même se
déclare fièrement antisémites en
racontant que dans sa jeunesse il aurait
il aurait endossé que le l'uniforme nazi
et et je vais d'occident mais le débat
est complètement fossier si vous voulez
leur bien sûr que leur balle doit son
élection une partie en trombe
si vous voulez électorale marginal mais
qui doit rapporter des points qui se
réclame et des antisémites de la sève de
la deuxième guerre mondiale mais c'est
marginal le fond du discours aujourd'hui
est partout dans le monde
ça reste un discours de de souveraineté
et d'être finalement m être maître chez
soi quelque part et je pense qu on va
sans doute assister à une mutation de la
cause palestinienne et peut-être que
finalement bas dans quelques années il y
aura singapour à gaza vous comprenez ce
que je veux dire avec une autre logique
qu'ils aient une logique constructive
voyez ce que je veux dire et là les
choses auront beau ça voudra dire que
jose ont évolué mais vu les accords qui
a aujourd'hui avec notre monde arabe
israël rivaux laisser à mon avis les
choses vont changer
merci beaucoup arnaudo thézac devoir
partager votre analyse ce matin sur la
tvh france je le rappelle vous êtes
géopolitologue chargé de cours à
l'université de genève